[Musik]
wie hart das Leben ist seit der Pandemie
das Erzählen Informanten direkt aus
Nordkorea sie beschreiben wie das Regime
die vergangenen drei Jahre dazu genutzt
hat Zäune entlang der Grenze nach China
zu bauen zuvor gelang es immerhin mehr
als tausend Menschen jedes Jahr aus
Nordkorea zu entkommen doch was in dem
Land wirklich passiert weitgehend
unbekannt
manchmal wird Nordkorea als schwarzes
Loch für Information beschrieben und
dieses Schwarze Loch ist deutlich
dunkler geworden in den vergangenen
Jahren
Journalisten der BBC haben über
Vermittler in Nordkorea monatelange
geheime Gespräche organisiert Menschen
erzählen von härteren Strafen
Medikamenten und Lebensmittelmangel die
Pandemie als Vorwand für Machthaber Kim
jongun sein Volk immer stärker zu
kontrollieren
die Informanten bleiben anonym deshalb
beschreiben wir mit animierten Bildern
den Alltag von drei Personen denn die
könnten sonst ihr Leben riskieren
eine von ihnen nennen wir Zug sie lebte
jahrelang davon Medikamente über die
nahe chinesische Grenze zu schmuggeln um
sie auf einem Markt zu verkaufen so
ernährte sie ihren Mann und zwei Kinder
jetzt kaum mehr möglich seit noch mehr
Bewacher an der Grenze patrouillieren
die meisten der Waren auf dem Markt
kamen aus China aber da ist nichts mehr
man konnte immer irgendwie Getreide
auftreiben aber jetzt nicht mehr unsere
Ernährungssituation war noch nie so
schlecht kürzlich klopften Leute an
unsere Tür und fragt nach Essen weil sie
so hungrig waren wie kalt
ist der Deckname dieses Mannes auch er
lebt mit seiner Familie nahe der Grenze
zu China der Bauarbeiter muss bis in die
Nacht arbeiten und auf der Baustelle
schlafen
die Versorgung mit Lebensmitteln ist so
schlecht die Leute beginnen zu sterben
es ist so lange her dass wir
Essensration von der Regierung bekam
aber irgendwie überlebt man während des
hartes nicht zu wissen wie lange noch in
dieser Armut die Zukunft des düster
Feature ist stark
[Musik]
hunderte Kilometer entfernt lebt die
dritte Informantin in der Hauptstadt
Pjöngjang in diesem Bericht heißt sie
chion sie arbeitet in einem
Lebensmittelgeschäft aus dem sie früher
schon mal Gemüse oder Obst mitnehmen
jetzt durchsuchen Sie gründlich unsere
Taschen das so kleines abzweigen nicht
mehr geht meine Familie hat nicht genug
zu essen mein Mann und ich überleben
indem wir immer zehn Tage weiter denken
dann nochmal 10 Tage überleben weil wir
befürchten dass wir verhungern wir
schaffen es aber wenigstens unsere
Kinder zu ernähren einmal habe ich zwei
Tage lang nichts gegessen nur Wasser
getrunken
für die un- untersucht James die
Menschenrechtslage in Nordkorea er soll
die Aussagen der drei Informanten
einschätzen
das ist ziemlich ernüchternd die
Informationen die Sie zusammengetragen
haben sind beunruhigend aber was
wahrscheinlich am schockierendsten ist
die Angst im Leben der Menschen das ist
besonders schlimm wir kennen das aus
früheren Zeiten aber das hier geht sogar
an die Grenze dessen was Menschen
ertragen können
es gibt viele Bettler wenn sie da so
liegen gucken wir nach ihnen und sehen
meistens dass sie tot sind
andere bringen sich zu Hause um oder
verschwinden in die Berge ich habe noch
nie von so etwas gehört
everyday jeden Tag wird das Leben
schwieriger eine falsche Bewegung und
man wird hingerichtet er verloren wenn
ich mich an die Regeln halte habe ich
das Gefühl zu verhungern aber wenn ich
nur versuche zu überleben könnte ich von
der Stadt Sicherheit verhaftet als
Verräter gebrandmarkt und getötet werden
der Sohn eines Freundes hat mir von
mehreren Hinrichtungen hinter
verschlossenen Türen erzählt die er
gesehen hat jedes Mal werden drei bis
vier Personen hingerichtet wir
Verbrechen war ein Fluchtversuch die
Menschen sitzen hier fest und warten auf
den Tod
für sein politisches Überleben rüstet
Kim Jong-un immer weiter auf seine
Atomwaffen könnten theoretisch die USA
erreichen Milliarden gibt er dafür aus
da bleibt wenig für sein Volk los
Nordkorea muss die Entbehrungen das
Leiden des Volkes rechtfertigen
sie sagen also da sind die Vereinigten
Staaten die eine feindliche macht sind
Südkorea das uns feindlich gesinnt ist
so wie Japan und das Atomprogramm ist
das einzige was die Nordkoreaner vor den
Feinden schützt dafür müssen wir Geld
ausgeben wir müssen unser Atomprogramm
ausbauen und das ist der Grund warum ihr
so leidet
nachdem sich unser oberster Führer mit
den USA getroffen hatte waren die
Menschen voller Hoffnung und froh dass
wir vielleicht ins Ausland würden reisen
können wir wurden getäuscht die
Grenzschließung nach China hat unser
Leben um 20 Jahre zurückgeworfen wir
fühlen uns zutiefst betrogen das Volk
wollte diese endlose Waffenentwicklung
nie
die Generation um Generation ins Elend
stürzt
ist ein hochrangiger Überläufer aus
Nordkorea bis 2019 war er Botschafter
für das Land etwa in cuade und Syrien
junge Generation denkt völlig anders als
wir
die fragt sich was haben das Land und
Kim Jong-un jemals für uns getan
dass wir nicht verhungern wenn Mut und
Unzufriedenheit weiter wachsen werden
sie irgendwann explodieren
[Musik]
doch die Menschen sind gefangen in ihrer
totalitären nordkoreanischen Welt
nach einer Stellungnahme befragt
antwortet die Regierung die
Informationen entsprechen nicht
vollständig den Fakten für die Regierung
habe das Wohl des Volkes immer an erster
Stelle gestanden
doch um seine Macht zu stärken lässt das
Regime Nordkoreas seine Bevölkerung
einsperren hungern und sterben
[Musik]